hi there
again natural language the natural
language society
today i want to talk about
another form of language learning which
is not natural which i came across today
someone sent me a youtube a video of tim
ferriss
who is now hosting a television
program
and
his his
theme is how to achieve sort of
accelerated learning
and tim is a very accomplished guy i am
very impressed uh i saw a video youtube
of him where he speaks spanish he speaks
excellent spanish i listened to him in
german it was not as good but still he's
able to express himself in german i
understand he speaks other languages i
take him at his word he is an
accomplished dancer ballroom dancer
martial arts expert
he does
pen tricks with his uh
hands i mean he
you know he does a lot of things and
there's a lot of video tube
uh videos uh uh at youtube of him doing
this good for tim i think he's a great
guy i'm very impressed
he
put up a blog post some while ago about
how to learn any language in an hour
uh i have commented on this in another
video it actually the the text itself
talks about how to quote deconstruct a
language in an hour in order to learn it
quickly which is not quite the same
thing but okay he's a good promoter
uh
his um
brief intro uh where he talks about his
his program and what we can expect
he sort of explains that the way you
accelerate learning is to deconstruct
the problem and put it back together
again whatever that means
in terms of language
i should go on record as saying i do not
think that that is possible
i do not think that a knowledge of how a
language is structured
is all that useful
in terms of learning the language
whether it's subject verb object or
subject object verb doesn't really
matter very much
those kinds of structural
patterns the brain will
find the rules for itself the brain will
gradually get used to them the big
challenge in learning a language is
words we need thousands of words unless
you just want to say hello how are you
i want a beer please if you want to get
beyond that if you want to understand
what people say to you
if you initiate a conversation what they
come back
at you with you want to understand those
things you need a lot of words
and it takes the brain a while to learn
these words you can't just review a list
of words and expect them to stick you
have to see the words in different
contexts so it gets back to my earlier
discussion about natural interesting
content to learn from so that you're
enjoying you're enjoying listening to
the language you're enjoying reading the
language you're enjoying reviewing words
which are meaningful to you because the
content was meaningful to you and the
words that you selected from that
meaningful content are also meaningful
to you
and the structure as well because any
language has simple structures
complicated structures the brain will
work that out little brain will identify
the structures that it needs now and it
will put aside the structures that it
doesn't understand and when it has
enough of the rest of the language these
other structures will become meaningful
unfortunately in unnatural learning such
as we have at school the teacher decides
what you're going to learn and you've
got to learn it here in chapter 2 and
you're going to get tested on it and if
you don't know it you're bad
the reality is the brain will decide
which words it's going to remember now
and which
words it's going to remember in six
months which structures is going to be
able to understand now and which
structures it's going to understand in
six months so that if we allow the brain
simply to learn
as a as the way it naturally learns and
develop rules for the language put
labels on words because every word you
learn in that language has a place in
your brain and the brain decides where
that place is going to be and eventually
you get better and better at retrieving
those words when you need them if you
learn naturally so i don't think
that learning a language should be a 100
yard dash
because you won't achieve it it should
be an enjoyable
natural process where the whole process
of learning is enjoyable and at every
step as you learn the language you
should be happy and feel satisfied at
what you have achieved that you now are
better able to communicate in a language
than you were before and there's no
pressure to speak until you're ready you
can simply as a normally my practice
spend a lot of time on enjoyable
listening and reading and take the time
that's required to learn the language so
today's little natural learning video is
to say don't rush it don't expect
shortcuts there are no shortcuts but if
you do it the natural way learning a
language can be very enjoyable and at
the end of that and really not only at
the end even during that period of
natural learning you can be satisfied
that you are doing something that is not
only useful to you but is also very good
for your brain so there you go that's
the
natural learning society
uh blurb of the day thank you